hey guys I'm Bryce ander and kandi
Burruss is here hello hello season 9 how
are you feeling about it because it
looks kinda crazy it is crazy um that
stressed me out this year I'm not even
gonna lie to you I'm like oh my god God
now what it just the already large we
fight each other I don't get baby how
are you feeling with like we are
definitely not cool
I'm done though I mean she made up stuff
like I got caught in so many lives this
year can't wait for you to see it are
you okay no I'm very happily married but
I will tell you you know I'm taking a
little step on the wild side before I
dip in the lady pond yes definitely but
you know I was like okay wait what's and
my answer to that is if I am then so she
give me your husband asked me and shamea
to come back to your house
okay indeed all right now I went along
with it but it was a Michigan about her
this was some years ago because it
wasn't on show or anything like that I
think she goes what never do that
you it's hot chick meets at least I try
to take me to a sex dungeon or when I I
mean I could not believe that she made
that up when I was telling you I was out
done I was out done I was like shocked
it would have been her word against mine
had it not been for somebody saying to
me like some weeks after I like I know
why she would say that when she knows it
you know she's text you something before
and I'm like text me something that made
me scroll through okay thank you Steve
Jobs yeah thank you you want piggy bank
and you bang your head so you don't say
I think I'm fans hockey Archelon for to
them my everybody basically that's lies
like so